[Musique]
la première fois que je me suis trouvé
comme ça en face d'une caméra
j'avais une notion de travailleuses
c'est à dire la pellicule et la caméra
qui tournait comme ça je voulais je
parlais très vite je veux surtout pas
déranger
j'étais là je voulais pas déranger je
voulais dire mon texte en un minimum de
temps que ce soit en même temps assez
bien et puis c'est tout pour moi c'est
très important une caméra qui tourne et
c'est m est pas trompé moi j'étais
l'employé je devais faire quelque chose
je te fais pas je trouvais pas le
plaisir je les trouvais pour la première
fois un jour dans une scène des
valseuses où tout d'un coup j'ai respiré
j'avançais calmement j'ai pris tout mon
temps j'ai eu le temps de penser tiens
là je vais dire cette phrase et je suis
très très bien
[Musique]
si j'avais une soif d'aventuré ou une
soif de toujours partir de gelée grâce
au cinéma je mène 10 mille vies comme ça
à fond je peux tuer sans être puni je
peux voler sans être puni je peux c'est
incroyable
[Musique]
allez non non alors comme dirait jean
ces marchands de cochon qui pensent à
juste c'est justement pour ça non alors
sans tabou du cheval voilà et avec une
petite en attendant justement un peu le
laisser aller à lire qu à y voilà oh oh
allez aux allées bon alors maintenant à
toi comme ses deux enfants
oui on gèle les jeunes d'un gène et la
jeanne
[Musique]
ça m'empêche pas du tout pensé au fait
au contraire je suis occupé là je suis
occupé à tout ça
[Musique]
j'en ai besoin j'ai besoin de cette
évidence c'est des évidences quand je
sens la tête de la petite jeanne la tête
d'angel je renifle comme ça c'est une
évidence comme la terre comme des choses
qu'on peut toucher et ça justement dans
le monde du cinéma
il n'ya rien d'évident où tout est
impalpable comme ça bah c'est ça me
paraît nécessaire aussi des grandes
aventures c'était chiant l'aventuré plus
grande quand on a le premier rôle
le premier rôle lumineux dansé toujours
plus d'intérêt que ce soit en bien sûr
puisqu'on est concerné bout en bout par
un film donc la première grande aventure
je suis je sais pas si on l'a dépassé
une fois c'était les valseuses grande
aventure de trois personnes
rarement on a une rencontre pareille est
aussi forte de ses trois villas en même
temps parce qu'on en voulait tellement
tous les trois et puis on s'aimait
depardieu dewaere et moi et il nous a
rassemblés en même temps pour moi bon
pour ce que j'étais tellement proches de
ce rôle de coiffeuse et de la part-dieu
très proche de ce rôle de moe ue et
patrick un peu moins de proches mais
cabine grande violence connaît et ça
fait vingt d'hésitation je pense en plus
toute l'équipe était jeune aussi comme
ça c'était leur premier truc c'était
formidable
après il ya eu d'autres aventures dans
un western là où c'était une aventure
éprouvante à coulx pourquoi je pense
qu'il ya des pics sommes d'accord je
t'ai pas parce que des pick up l'autre
moitié marche c'est très doux les autres
films souvent des rencontres
je pense à bondues golson c'était autre
chose encore
puis c'est toujours lié à la vie jeudi
du lawson jeu tourné avec patrick après
je filme de jean-pierre blanc d'amour et
d'eau fraîche qui n'a pas marché
d'ailleurs et du tout et que j'ai fait
avec julien donc tout ça se liant dans
la vie privée comme ça et puis donc ça
c'est pour moi c'est une aventure les
rencontres avec ces gens là
non non non puis me l'air très important
danner aussi le film suisse jonas comme
ça très bien bellocchio
on ne peut plus dire j'ai tourné avec un
tel jeu tourne avec intel je crois pas
je crois qu'on pu le dire parce que ce
n'est pas un nom maintenant ne fait plus
infime des fois il ya aucun nom et ça
fait des films formidables
bon il ya des rencontres qui sont ils se
font pas comme moi je rate une rencontre
raté une rencontre je veux dire que pour
moi le film dure de l'osé c'est une
rencontre qui s'est pas fait et au
départ je vois pas maintenant avec le
recul comme ça je ne vois pas pourquoi
elle se serait fait
[Musique]
hu
j'aime bien plaire je dire j'aime bien
faire des films qui me plaisent et qui
j'espère vont plaire mais j'espère
vraiment que ça va plaire
moi j'aime faire les deux genres de
films j'aime bien faire des films
faciles qui aide énormément les films
plus difficile après par exemple le fait
d'avoir fait des choses avec lautner qui
est un monsieur que j'adore hamon les
gens aiment ces films donc vous voir ses
films ça fait des succès
[Musique]
en ce moment les metteurs en scène du
fait que j'ai fait l'état nerfs le
tanneur et bellocchio tout d'un coup on
a eu envie de moi des metteurs en scène
comme ça qui avant n'y aurait sûrement
repensé ils ont pensé à moi j'en suis
très bien j'ai des scénarios formidable
j'en ai jamais autant d vraiment très
très bon rien ne marche
rien ne se produit rien à rien de ce
fait tout est bloqué blocs est bloqué
mais en même temps patrick m'a fait rire
ce que votre il m'a dit mais c'est pas
le cinéma qui est ancré c'est tout le
pays et on se plaint de la crise du
cinéma je veux dire en même temps c'est
embêtant parce que chaque fois que les
acteurs viennent à la télévision censée
faire la fête je parlais de cérémonie de
choses comme ça c'est d'une tristesse
épouvantable ça pleurait carrément sans
quoi tu parle là précisément
oui ça va être non je parle tout vous
dire j'ai vu la remise du prix à cannes
où là où j'ai pleuré de rire
enfin dans l'autre sens au ska p c'était
incroyable cette remise des prix à
cannes comme ça il y avait bon les
césars où c'est un monument je dire
c'est extraordinaire ça sent la
poussière ça alors que ça devrait être
la fête de l'imagination de dollar et
tout ça
on a un peu terminé le genre ou madame
on fait un film
voilà tant de milliards pour vous
accepter de le faire je crois que c'est
fini je crois qu'il faut se battre pour
monter des films
pour monter des films qu'on aime il faut
que les acteurs aient offert bon et puis
on va voir il ya plein de petits
producteurs plein de petits acteurs je
ne peux tu metteur en scène je crois que
finalement la grande famille du cinéma
comme il disait je trouve c'est c'est
pas vrai ça n'existe pas il ya des
petites familles oui il ya des petites
familles bien sûr qu'ils existent et on
va trouver des solutions puis si je vais
pas signer match faut que tu veux c'est
pas grave j'ai ma soeur avec ses deux
enfants enfin il ya ce côté d'attraits
finalement on a quatre enfants comme ça
ils sont toujours ensemble toujours jeu
julien parce que je les aime et puis
voilà en quoi amour de tous les sens et
s'équivaut d'abba
[Musique]
je sais que ma vie soit remis je sais qu
il pas un décalage entre la belle entre
ce que je fais ce que je pense quand
même mais j'essaie toujours gardé cette
harmonie cette harmonie cet équilibre là
parce que je sais aussi que c'est
fragile simple ça peut casser surtout
dans le cinéma ça casse on peut devenir
fou le colis tous ont fait de manière
benchoud c'est tellement c'est tellement
fait pour ça quoi
[Musique]